here's another case study I simply put
two pieces of paper overlapping these
papers are used for particular medical
analysis so i captured it once again at
a very high resolution so that as we
zoom into the image we can actually see
the fibers in the paper here's an image
where I added background color now I'm
not changing the important information
in the image the structure the structure
is the data I'm just adding an
additional component to allow the viewer
to see the material better we'll be
looking at adding backgrounds in the how
to do it section I want to spend a few
minutes on backgrounds I am a bit of a
background collector and frankly I think
you should be 12 really it helps a lot
to imagine your images even while you're
not even working on it whenever some
interesting envelope or card arrives in
my mailbox I keep it believe it or not
thinking that it might help with an
image one day or platters or wired
thingies anything that might be
appropriate for a background for small
devices and besides it's fun to think
about so let's take a look at one
particular idea take this simple graph
paper which I tried as a background for
this device looks ok here I tried some
bubble wrap of all things definitely
over the top and doesn't work quite well
there should be some sort of intelligent
visual connection between your device
and your background and bubble wrap
doesn't quite cut it in the end I
finally landed on using simple green
paper with this device and because the
image was captured with the scanner
setting at a high resolution it was
about 400 Meg file I was able to zoom in
crop and finalize the image I think that
both the simple colored background and
the composition works
here we see three microfluidic devices
which I initially lined up in a pretty
boring way as you see here and once
again I'm always playing with
composition so what I did was I used two
of them instead just the two of them
really visually say what you need to say
we don't need three you might think
about that in your own work so i
captured it at a very high resolution
putting the devices on an angle much
more interesting composition and because
of the high resolution i was able to
zoom in and crop the image now watch
what happens when i enhance the image
using a sharpening tool will talk about
sharpening images on the how to do it
section this is an important technique
the sharpening filter is not changing
your data if your data is about form and
structure it's permitting you and your
viewers to see the image clearly but
whenever any of these filters are used
it's imperative to always indicate the
process in the caption something that I
encourage you to consider because I
captured this at such a high resolution
we can zoom in and see 30 micron
structure here it is again first the
original image and here it is sharpened
where you can really see the detail it's
pretty neat so this is our first week
imaging with a flatbed scanner think
about it it's not an expensive piece of
equipment and if used properly you can
achieve high quality images without
spending an inordinate amount of time in
the next week's we'll talk about cameras
lenses lighting approaches to imaging
science and engineering we'll also
discuss how to graphically use these
images for figures and potential cover
designs so lots more ahead and I look
forward to it